I'm forward in time to view alternate
futures how many did you see 14 million
605 how many real in the culmination of
21 movies 10 years in the making and
this is what they come up with it's
brilliant
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the rear end game of YouTube so it's
finally here after a year of waiting
we're finally gonna find out how a team
of superheroes defeats the strongest
person in the universe how they're able
to topple a warrior so great that he
controls all the elements of time space
and reality people are so excited to see
the conclusion of this story that
presale tickets have been sold out for
months but you know what us online
already know the real story we know how
this whole thing wraps up and no it's
not because we watch the leaks on
Twitter well everyone else is like oh
time travel us intellectuals know the
real answer and it's double what
although there's a lot of different
variations to this theory online they
all come out something like this using
ant-man suit Scott Lang will shrink
himself down crawl into Thanos his poop
chute and expand back to normal size
killing the mad Titan once and for all
by literally ripping Thanos a new one
surprisingly enough this theory first
appeared on reddit back in 2017 before
Avengers infinity war was even released
in June 2018 YouTube entertainment
outlet entertainment dot I actually sat
down and asked Paul Rudd about the
theory to which he responded I almost
think it's a question for Thanos if
there's one thing we learned from
infinity war then fan o's can he could
take a lot of punishment it's an
interesting sin it's an it's an
interesting tweet look at how nervous he
gets after this is brought up you can
tell that we're on to something so this
was probably the first time that it was
really brought to Marvel's attention but
soon afterward they really started to
get in on the joke Thanos actor Josh
Brolin got involved posting a video of
himself on a toilet to his Instagram
account along with the hashtag flush and
hand man shortly thereafter the killer
of memes himself PewDiePie called me out
on it again we are not making any
assumptions this is just a theory you
know what
you are absolutely right we don't want
to make any assumptions which is why
since the day you made that video I have
been researching this thing to get you
felix the most accurate scientifically
correct answer possible because if
there's one thing I know the meme
community appreciates it is hard-hitting
scientific research on the realism of an
alien's butthole so today Thanos is
gonna find a bug up his butt but is that
gonna be enough to kill him
using my all-powerful theorist stone I
can only see two possible outcomes here
one Ant Man could succeed and give
Thanos the most explosive diarrhea of
his life or two ant man's expansion is
no match for Thanos as purple rectum and
would actually be crushed himself when
he tries to expand would be like the
trash compactor scene from Star Wars
except in Reverse interestingly enough
both of these outcomes do have precedent
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe in the
original Ant Man film Scott Lang runs
through an tunnels as one does before
expanding to normal size and breaking
through the ground whoever in Ant Man
and the wasp ant-man attempts to expand
but ultimately gets constrained by the
walls of the room around him the first
example shows us that Ant Man is
expanding with enough force to break
through the layers of the earth above
him but the second example shows us that
it's not so much force that he can break
through a wall additionally you'll
notice that he expands as much as he can
to fill that larger space which can
leave him in some pretty tight and very
uncomfortable positions Oh certainly not
as uncomfortable as he will be soon
enough
the universe demands that ant-man oh and
just a quick insert here as we're
finishing the Edit on this episode a
video on this exact topic was just
released yesterday by my friend Kyle
Hill on his channel because science and
apparently he used some of the exact
same examples that I did in that
previous section I'm just gonna leave a
link to it in the description it's
actually a really fun analysis analysis
but before anyone goes claiming that one
person is ripping off the other we've
actually been working on this particular
episode since April 2nd and we actually
wound up using a different methodology
than Kyle to solve this exact problem
which is actually a really cool
coincidence since if we both come to the
same conclusion by the end of this
episode well we just kind of verified
each other's answers on this very
fictional very bizarre scenario
so anyway I just wanted to call that out
before we got much deeper into this
video we all good we good Kyle I love
you great minds think alike keep up the
awesome work man by the way since I'm
talking to you right now your mortal
combat series is phenomenal okay so the
key to this theory is understanding the
relationship between stress and strain
and no we're not talking about the
emotions that I feel when I think about
how many more scripts I have to write
this week no in material physics stress
is defined as the internal pressure of
an object while strain is the amount
that that material expands as a result
of stress so for every material these
two things start out in a linear
relationship that's defined by Hookes
law when one goes up the other one goes
up proportionally which makes sense when
you think about it if you put stress on
any material it stretches when you let
it go it snaps back this is called
fittingly enough the elastic region so
in order to survive this back attack
thanos better hope his region is pretty
darn lastic I'm sure hook must be
rolling over in his grave right now
knowing that his law is being used for
something like this the relationship
between stress and strain is unique for
every material which also makes sense
you can push really hard on a piece of
steel and it's barely gonna stretch or
plastic and it's probably gonna stretch
a lot more because plastic is just a lot
more elastic when you graph the
relationship between stress and strain
they create what engineers called a
stress-strain curve because engineers at
least in this case don't come up with
fun titles for things taking a look at
it notice how this curve looks a little
wonky like it starts out straight and
then it goes all bendy point a on this
graph is where the material being tested
no longer obeys Hookes law in real life
you would say that this is where the
material starts to act a little funny
and you start getting into territory
where you could start doing some damage
point B of our little graph is called
the elastic limit of the object and it's
the point where if you push on the
object anymore you're gonna permanently
deform it taking this hypothetical
example straight up Thanos his rear end
this is the point where if you were
pushing on his internal organs like say
his colon from the inside it wouldn't
exactly snap back you'd start doing
serious damage to tissues maybe even as
: walls would start to deform
permanently but we need to go way beyond
that if ant-man is actually gonna leave
lasting impression on Thanos his
digestive tract so we need point D the
ultimate tensile strength point that
represents the maximum amount of stress
the object can receive and then after
this point the material goes through a
process called necking which is the
weird word to use when you're thinking
about a purple aliens chubby cheeks
necking is where the material continues
to expand but it stretches and gets
really thin and so translating this into
our hypothetical Marvel scenario this is
where we'd have more and more of Thanos
as anal tissue start to give way as
ant-man's rapidly expanding suit
explodes like a trip to the toilet after
Chipotle finally we get ourselves all
the way to point E this is the fracture
point the point where the object breaks
this is the point where there is no more
cushion for the pushin and ant-man
breaks out let me just take this
opportunity to remind you all that you
asked for this theory I wash my hands of
this mostly because that's what you're
supposed to do after you get all up in
someone's butt great now it's time to
take fan oohs his butt and plug in some
numbers crazy enough some scientists in
the Journal of biomechanics actually
produced a stress-strain curve for the
human rectum this is where all that
important scientific grant money goes
ladies and gentlemen looking at the
curve they constructed it's apparent
that the fracture point has a stress of
about 0.85 mega pascals and an
elongation of 60 percent the original
size of the rectum before it bursts open
now while that may sound like a lot
because it has a mega in the name it
actually doesn't stack up all that well
compared to other materials around us as
a point of reference rubber has a
fracture point of 16 mega Pascal's
whereas a human rectum is less than 1 so
at first blush it doesn't look like it
should be that hard to make this theory
work and that's good because
realistically ant-man needs to blow this
level of pressure away I mean it's one
thing to break through the colon wall
but unless ant-man has taken down panels
big explosion this guy literally has the
power of the universe in his hands and
would easily be able to repair his own
rectum if he got the chance using any
number of stones in the gauntlet reality
stone boom my colon is now made of steel
space stone boom I've created a portal
in my butt to avoid ant-man injuring my
bum bum' power stone ooh I some of the
world's greatest fart and blast ant-man
into the quantum realm you get the idea
so a man gets one shot let's see if this
theory holds up or if it's just a
crocodiie do there is no obvious method
to calculate the expanding force of Ant
Man but I chose to use momentum as a
general rule of thumb if the situation
involves contact between two bodies well
then you should probably use momentum to
solve it and this theory involves plenty
of contact between two bodies momentum
is equal to mass of an object multiplied
by velocity ant-man's mass is never
specified by the MCU
so I just used the weight of Paul Rudd
in real life which is 171 pounds or
seventy-seven point five six kilograms
using frame-by-frame measurements you're
able to determine that Ant Man grows
ninety-seven point four three
centimeters in point two two seconds
which produces an average velocity of
four point four to eight meters per
second at a momentum of three hundred
and forty three point five Newton's
seconds that number doesn't mean a whole
lot so let's keep going since the
collision of the two objects ant man's
body and Thanos as you know will be over
the span of point two two seconds we can
calculate the average force using the
impulse equation force equals momentum
divided by time this gives us an average
force of 1561 Newtons or about half the
maximum force that olympic-caliber
weightlifters can achieve after
converting that force to a pressure
which equals 3181 Pascal's we can
finally calculate the tensile strength
and then compare it with the ultimate
tensile strength that we found earlier
if we assume that colons are basically
cylinders which is a pretty reasonable
assumption we can use this handy dandy
equation the tensile strength exerted on
the walls of the intestine is equal to
the internal pressure multiplied by the
ratio of the cylinders radius to the
thickness of the walls according to a
study by the National Institute of
Health ratio here would be 25 plugging
in all
those numbers the final tensile stress
of ant-man expanding in the colon is
seventy nine thousand five hundred and
25 Pascal's this is certainly a
significant amount of stress but it
comes nowhere close to the required
eight hundred and fifty thousand
Pascal's that we determined earlier
looking back at that stress-strain curve
for the human rectum this amount of
pressure would cause Thanos his
intestines to expand by sixty percent
which is impressive but nowhere close to
the two hundred eighty percent that we
need to break it ant-man would barely
get to be more than a moderately sized
poo in there not to be too graphic but
also you know what you're getting
yourself into when you clicked on this
video in fact not only does ant-man not
put a dent in that OSes but literally or
figuratively it's actually safe to
assume that this maneuver would
completely backfire ultimately this
would kill ant-man consider this Steve
and w Cranford an engineering professor
at Northeastern University actually
calculated the strength of Thanos and
concluded how much stronger he would be
than a normal human being yes a
real-life college professor at a
respected university actually spent time
thinking through this and then wrote it
up and published a paper he's looking
for a new job
get offer him tenure or anything but I
can't offer him more time to look at
stupid stuff like this the paper titled
compressive failure of a carbon nano
tesseract sci-fi inspired materials and
the strength of Thanos found that Thanos
has the grip strength of 750,000 times a
typical person given the unbelievable
difference in muscle strength and Thanos
it's pretty safe to assume that his
rectal muscles are gonna be a lot
stronger too he might also have himself
a souped up intestinal tract and if the
smooth muscles of his colon reflect even
a portion of his increased strength Ant
Man is gonna find himself in some
serious trouble
not only as ant-man failing to expand
beyond the human body's colon strength
it also means that he's failing to
expand beyond the tensile strength of
Thanos his body as a whole that mega
strength : of Thanos would actually end
up crushing Scott
remember the trash compactor example I
mentioned at the beginning of the
episode well if ant-man can't stop his
expansion and Thanos his colon is
stronger than ant man's expansion forces
are it's not the colon that's getting
damaged here it's Ant Man himself that's
right Ant Man would literally be crushed
from every angle of his body by Thanos
his super-powered bowels a man killed
half the universe with a snap and one
more for good measure with the sphincter
either that are like half of ant man's
body will squirt out as old poop chute
with his head still up then you know
what never mind personally I'm just sad
to see this theory go in fact I'm
crushed but then again so is Ant Man
crushed within Thanos is beefy buttocks
and that's why this is just a theory
film theory and now that we've kicked
this meme in the well you know there's
one thing left that we got a kick paying
too much for online purchases and for
that you don't need the help of a
superhero you need the help of a super
sponsor and that super sponsors name is
honey sure the Avengers may or may not
be able to take down Thanos an end game
but honey will sure take down the prices
that you're paying for pretty much
everything you buy online and you know
what we've talked about honey a lot on
both film theory and game theory we
appreciate honey's sponsorship of these
episodes but we also appreciate the
amazing service that it provides and you
guys also seem to appreciate them too
from the time we started getting
sponsored by honey you guys have sent us
tweets and messages about really saving
money with every online purchase that
you're making thanks to honey and that's
pretty awesome because most times when
people are talking about online services
they're just talking about them to
complain but people like at Cassidy's
underscore YouTube tweeted at me to say
thanks to you I saved 68 dollars and 30
cents on my holiday shopping which kept
me under budget so I can get more gifts
thank you you know what Cassidy you're
welcome and thank you for supporting
honey like I say every time they sponsor
us they deliver a quality product that's
helping you save money by doing
absolutely nothing all you do is make
your purchase and boom look at all this
money that you're saving great just
click the box but you know what even if
you're not shopping for huge gifts it
when you're just treating yourself one
person who raided the app on Google Play
said I originally found this extension
because it was a paid sponsor of game
theory on YouTube and honestly it's my
favorite extension out there I save
money on more than just big orders but
stuff like when I order peeps online
it's so convenient
any person who shops online regularly
must have this this isn't coming from me
it's coming from people who listen to my
advice during these little promo spots
and are now saving money with every
purchase they make online money that
they would just be throwing away if it
wasn't for their use of honey it's true
it's great it's completely free and it's
just two clicks to install and from that
point forward it automatically finds
every discount code coupon deal and
insider savings pass on the internet and
I get what your hesitation might be
right it seems too good to be true it
seems too easy how can something save me
free money without me having to pay for
it where's the catch here well it's
actually really simple whenever you use
a coupon code provided by honey they
earn a small commission from the
merchant that you're buying from and
then they pass along some of those
savings back to their members so really
it's a win-win-win for everyone you win
because you save money on something that
you wanted to buy the merchant wins
because they sold the product that they
were looking to sell and honey wins
because they're helping you save money
they're helping the merchants sell their
product and they're getting a little cut
on the side it's great there is
literally no reason not to install it
link is in the top line of the
description or heck you can type into
the URL bar join honeycomb slash film
theorists fi lm th e Ori STS which is
really long just click the link in the
top line of description and from there
like I said just two clicks away it is
that easy
so go join the 10 million people who are
already saving money on all their
purchases across 20,000 sites
everything from Amazon to Pizza Hut and
Sephora to Best Buy you guys have told
me that it saved you money on everything
from new laptops to cosplay supplies to
shoes to switches so get out there
treat yourself and you know what don't
spend so much while you're doing it link
is in that top line of the scription
it's join honey comps
- film theorists get going friends and
then get going to see Avengers endgame
cuz you know there's gonna be some
theories coming out of that one along
with ant-man coming out Thanos his buddy
had to do it one last time before the
episode ended